so dave ramsey probably doesn't need an
introduction but for anybody who's been
living under a rock his show the ramsay
show is the second biggest radio talk
show in america with over one billion
downloads he's written two new york
times bestsellers has over two and a
half million subscribers across two
youtube channels and owns over 600
million dollars cash worth of real
estate dave is actually somebody who
i've personally looked up to now for 10
years and if you don't believe me i
literally have a cat named after him
because i found the cat for free and i
have a life-sized cardboard cutout of
him in my family room needless to say
dave ramsey is the king of all financial
entertainment well we got him for an
exclusive one-hour long episode here on
the iced coffee hour and couldn't be
more excited to show you so if you're a
fan of this content and you want to see
more subscribe because we have some
pretty incredible stuff coming out in
the near future but first we want to
thank our sponsor wealthfront with all
that's going on in the market right now
investing can be seen as very risky and
it would be incredible if there is a
guaranteed way to get a high interest
return on your money well thankfully
there is and it's by using today's
sponsor wealthfront wealthfront this is
saving an investing app that can help
you earn more in your money and start
building wealth for your future that's
because the wealthfront cash account
gives everyone a two percent apy
interest rate which is 20 times what
traditional banks pay wealthfront only
takes a few minutes to sign up and you
can start earning two percent apy
immediately they've been a company that
i've been personally using for a few
years now and at two percent interest
it's pretty much higher than almost
every other option out there so i would
highly recommend them and if you start
now you'll get a free 50 bonus with a
500 deposit there are already nearly
half a million people using wealthfront
to save more earn more and build
long-term wealth so why wait so earn two
percent in your cash today by visiting
wealthfront.com
ich the link is down below in the
description or again it's
wealthfront.com ich this no-brainer good
news has been a paid endorsement by
wealthfront thank you so much
wealthfront once again link down below
and back to the podcast i'm george
campbell
and i'm not i'm dave ramsey and this is
the iced coffee hour and so far this
podcast wild guess has made
260 thousand dollars
you're officially our closest guest
congratulations actually good job
usually we just say this you know if
you're within you know a little bit but
yeah two hundred and fifty eight
thousand seven hundred dollars so you're
thirteen hundred dollars this was price
is right i would have won the dishwasher
one dollar bomb
well thank you guys so much for doing
this and uh dave the hospitality of
everyone that i've met on your team is
insane just how passionate everyone is
how much they really want to be here how
excited they are how nice it's like i am
blown away when we drove down here and
saw we were asking uh your driver are
your head of security actually i said is
this all dave's he's got the whole thing
and it's all paid for it's all owned out
right and i'm like does he sublease any
of it surely there must be like other
like medical buildings or off no
i am blown away
insane now for those unfamiliar i bet
most people are familiar with your story
um
could you give us a bit of a background
on what you do your philosophies and how
you were able to to go from being
bankrupt in your 20s to owning
everything it's incredible
i'm at a loss for words here wow
i like hanging out with graham
ideas
uh now we uh
like you said we started with nothing
mom and dad were in the real estate
business and so i know your background
of course
uh your parents weren't but you got into
it at 18. i got my license when i turned
three weeks after i turned 18
and still got my license and a thousand
years later and so
uh i went and got my degree in real
estate came out sharon and i got married
at 22 years old 1982. and went through a
couple jobs and then i quickly started
buying real estate nothing down in those
days it was a big deal before there was
um before chip and joanna were born you
know and so
it's a long time ago and i got rich i
had a million dollar net worth made
about 200 i think i made 250 000 bucks
at uh 24 years old and that's 1984. so
that's that's like making 600 500 000
now you know so uh
it was for a kid from antioch tennessee
i mean where i came from that's called
rich and so everything was going great
but i
did a lot of 90 day notes because i was
doing flips
a lot of short term notes and uh our
bank got the the largest bank i had a
million two out with them got sold to
another bank and outside of the state of
tennessee and some guy looks down in
another city and said hey there's a 24
year old kid owes us a million bucks
this is scary
let's let's limit this relationship
which is banker talk for ruin his life
and they called her notes uh another
banker got word we were in trouble
called another eight hundred thousand so
we had two million we had to come up
with in 120 days and it's all in real
estate you can't get out of it that fast
so it started a crash that
uh that i couldn't recover from and we
spent the next two and a half years
losing everything we owned being sued
and foreclosed on and
finally with a brand new baby and a
toddler and our marriage hanging on by a
thread we filed bankruptcy in september
of 88 and um it was not a good ride but
we uh
uh
we were
new in our christian faith baby
christians and i started studying what
the bible says about money which was
just common sense get out of debt
stay out of debt live on less than you
make live on a budget have a plan
uh and i started doing this stuff and
that evolved into people asking me okay
how are you recovering from your
bankruptcy
it seems like you're doing okay and i'm
like well we're doing okay it wasn't
fast
but um
we finally sat down with some friends
and helped them do a budget because they
were in trouble
and then pastor called from the church
and said hey this guy's in foreclosure
can you help him i went yeah i used to
buy foreclosures and then i was one so
yeah i could probably help him so we
sat down did uh uh you know did a
workout plan a forbearance plan with
that mortgage company for him and
um i started doing uh forbearance plans
for people that were behind on their
mortgage started helping people that
were struggling so they didn't have to
file bankruptcy they thought they would
have to go into chapter 13 or
to save their house and then that
evolved and um started teaching a little
sunday school class and there's about
four people in there and looked up and
there were 300 people in there and it
just there was such a need people were
they gravitated to my story of stupidity
my phd in dumb and uh
they were hurting too and it gave them
an authentic place to get help by
somebody who actually knew the pain and
knew the stress and from there we i went
on a broke radio station that was in
chapter 11 bankruptcy a lot of
bankruptcy in this story but the uh
and uh
they let us work for free uh which is
exactly what we were worth
and we were
horrible
daryl and his other brother daryl on
doing talk radio it was nasty and um
you know we were able to sell some a
little bit of that first book i wrote
out of the trunk of my car and
uh started doing some events with
overhead projector in a bad suit and you
know fast forward all of that to
this massive thing starting all that
stuff was about 30 years ago starting
the radio show was 30 years this year
how were you able to turn that into a
business though because it seems like at
the beginning you were giving free
advice just helping other people out
from the church
how did that evolve into
making money from it or being able to
grow that
and hire so many people well we started
i mean i started the first thing i did
was i thought okay i can do counseling
we now call it coaching but um
uh counseling has got legal implications
in the word but the uh coaching people
in their finances and so i would charge
250 or 750 to help somebody and just
meet in a conference room and sit down
and help them do that
uh outside of church i mean just word
got out you know a guy
at a red local restaurant heard i was
helping people and he sent one of his
employees over who had an irs lien and
was getting the irs is getting ready to
tag his house and so we were able to get
that
get an oic working on that and um so i
just started coaching people helping
them with their budgets and avoiding a
foreclosure repo or whatever all stress
stuff all hurting stuff and then i went
on this little radio show
and we weren't making any money on it we
didn't make money the radio show wasn't
profitable for 10 years but it was i
mean we didn't make 258 000 i can
promise you that um
and uh but the uh there were a lot of
people listening and it became a a
megaphone a way to get to to acquire
customers so they would come in and do
coaching and we could sell books and
then we started doing events that we
charged for
and then we opened up a thing called
life after debt which was a 26-week
course on money to get out of debt it
evolved into what's now known as
financial peace university which is now
nine weeks mercifully you know that grew
the events grew the publishing grew the
speaking grew
uh and finally the radio show became
profitable we were able to actually sell
some ads
in our talk radio slots other than just
trying to promote our own stuff which
was kind of infomercial-ish really but
in every case we just figured out a
different medium or media
to help people
and then was there a way to monetize
that too where we could help people make
a little money and
you know if you sell a ten dollar book
and you make eight dollars on it or
whatever that's good but if you're
selling me and i miss better yeah and in
that beginning phase when you were just
getting started did you guys do any
marketing to try to grow these different
businesses that you were in or was it
mostly just word of mouth and people
telling their friends and their family
hey you should listen to this guy he's
got some great financial
adv advice right entertainment yeah
entertainment it was mainly word of
mouth but we had this wonderful
microphone of this radio station
and the little radio station ended up
getting bought out of bankruptcy and by
then we had marshalled a following
we didn't even know we had ratings
because they never told us to say that
call letters we were in bankruptcy it
was like it was like a saturday night
live skit i mean it was bad and so then
this professional radio people come in
and start teaching us you say the call
letters you're kind of illegal if you
don't say them once an hour you know and
so and so we started using them in and
out of every call
and
and so the radio show ended up building
the the critical mass from a marketing
perspective we didn't have any money to
do marketing
we were just surviving
taking payroll on friday and so the
first guy i hired was a another
financial coach because i was maxed out
logistically
then i hired a lady to help us in the
office and
you know and then financial peace
university started taking off we put it
on video and quit teaching it live
and boy that went to scale quick it's
now been taught about 10 million people
been through it in 50 000 churches but
that
you know when we put it on video that
enabled
on vhs okay later dvd now
you know obviously digitally delivered
yeah it was uh when we changed the
mechanisms of the delivery we started
seeing scale
kick out on the different things and
then we started getting more radio
stations to add start syndicating the
show meaning we would try to get other
cities on to carry us and so forth and
um you know we just i remember when we
got to 10 radio stations i thought oh my
god i'm in 10 cities
wow am i a big deal what
you know and now it's 670 or something
like that it's crazy is there a reason
you did radio over tv yeah i've got a
face for radio
no hey nobody nobody would let me on tv
i mean i get them news media hits
here or there or when we did a book tour
i got i got on the today show the first
time with that first book
uh when i sold it to a publisher and
then we went we re-issued relaunched it
and they
uh got on the today show i thought oh
god this is it it's over man i just just
checked that box man
and uh nobody even knew i was on there
it's great
you know i sold some books though we got
it on the new york times and um
then people magazine picked it up and so
we you know we ended up getting kind of
in the pub business the publicity
business we started figuring out oh
that's like free marketing hello
and so if we can provide content for
them they'll have us on their shows and
it doesn't cost a thing they benefit we
benefit the viewer listener benefits but
i wasn't good at tv i did uh when fox
business first launched
their their uh initial launch i was one
of the first i was the show in the
evening i was a prime time show we did a
one-hour show on there uh that aired in
the evening
and i learned a lot tv's a lot harder
than radio it's a lot and um people
talking in your ear while you're
supposed to be talking my brain's not
that good i'm not smart enough to do
that so but we got through it and we did
that for two years and fox business
shifted their
aim at a different demographic our
demographic's pretty young
and fox business at that time was a very
old demographic
and so we we weren't a help to them
nothing at that point so anyway but i
did a little while but i really wasn't
good at it i'm really good at like the
three minute interview thing
you know like on fox and friends i do
that all the time from here we've got
fiber into here they're friends we they
the [ __ ] that's funny fox friends are
friends but george and i do that you
know all the ramsey personalities we'll
jump on and do those i'm really good at
those but the long-form tv thing is just
what that is i don't i think there's
just so many things going on and you
have to concentrate and
you have to look at the camera properly
and yeah i just talk it's funny that's
long but he does a three-hour radio show
first i know i was just thinking that an
hour of tv is just too long because like
taking like a dr phil format for
personal finance and finding really just
extreme situations but helping them
through that i feel like would be so
interesting but before we go into that
we gotta thank our sponsor ftxus now as
some of you may have noticed
cryptocurrency prices have declined
quite a bit since their peak which means
you're buying it a lot cheaper today
than you were just a few months ago and
when it comes to that that is where ftx
us wants to help they've got fees up to
85 percent lower than top competitors
and they also make it extremely easy to
trade yeah jack all you got to do is uh
type in what you want to buy how much
you want to buy how often you want to
buy it and then you swipe right and
you're done without any additional work
on your end plus you get free crypto in
every single trade you make over ten
dollars and by the way guys this is a
secret graham can't know this but
they're soon launching ftx stocks so
they're gonna be an all-in-one inclusive
finance app where you can trade crypto
nfts and stocks all for extremely low
fees and ftx also recently spent 250
million dollars expanding their equity
trading infrastructure to make sure that
you can trade stocks without any fees
whatsoever and on top of all that guys
they've seriously been a huge supporter
of this podcast like sponsoring us and
making sure we can do what we do every
week for you guys so it would mean a lot
if you would check them out with that
link down below in the description again
the link is down below to get started
today and now let's get back to the
podcast cbs had us do a pilot yeah when
the nanny was hot you remember the oh
yes yeah she would come in and fix the
mean kids or whatever what was that the
english it was the english ladies yeah
yeah so about that time i did
we ran around all over the country we
had three families to do it shoot this
pilot and their idea was that we would
be like the nanny but in finance we'd
come in and swoop in and help this
couple and so forth then it was
it was really bad it was awful you
didn't like the way it turned out no it
was they they didn't mean they didn't
even air the pipeline oh wow it sucked
it's got to be on the internet i
wouldn't
it sucked it it really sucked and it was
it was me was it just boring to me
yeah it's just it's just i mean well i
mean it's real the funny thing is
reality tv has absolutely nothing to do
with reality like i remember walking up
to the doorbell at these people's house
and ringing the doorbell
i did it like 17 times before they got
the take they wanted i'm like it's
ringing a doorbell this is supposed to
be real i just ring the dad blame things
17
takes to get the doorbell right yeah i'm
not going to screw this i'm not i'm not
any good at this but see at this point
you would be able to produce your own
show if you really wanted to and it
would be a hit yeah you could ring the
doorbell once yeah actually actually
we're gonna do that with george oh my
god are you actually way less
intimidating if dave ramsey shows up at
your house and hits that doorbell yes
like oh crap yeah yeah they would be
quivering
here why why am i a fearful character
like hey what's wrong with your money
you show up and like oh gosh yeah like
what did i do i'm i'm getting just
yelling out more of a colleague more of
a uh gordon ramsay i was about to say
yeah
the kitchen was it kitchen nightmare
where he goes in the restaurants and
fixes the restaurants but he you got to
be shouting half the time yeah yelling
at them and be rating
and you're going to be doing that i
don't want to make you have that kind of
energy no you don't care
yelling is a different vibe than dave
got it okay don't yell
listen to the radio show today he will
be yelling
that's interesting how many people now
do you have working with you uh we got
about 1200 in the building wow now i've
heard and i've listened to other
interviews you've done that the uh the
interview process to work with you is
pretty stringent
how many people uh apply for a job
versus how many people get one and what
what's the process like for you to hire
somebody well i i don't hire yeah i mean
they were hired inside our leadership
team does the hiring
the chances of me i'm not very good at
interviewing people so i'm they don't
let me do it um
the idea just being that we want people
that are on mission and on crusade
and that align with our values and
that's who we want the building we have
had really bad experience with people
who were here
for what they could get
rather than what they could add
they're takers rather than givers they
don't add value and people that add
value generally are people that are
aligned on our values
they add value if they're excited about
the crusade of helping people with their
mental health or their career or their
money or they want to help with that and
even if you know it's a
creative they want to do their creative
work for something that matters you know
but if you're just looking for a job we
want to weed you out before you get in
here or if you're crazy we'd like to
find that out before you get in here
um
and so we don't just
open a open a wreck for
a hire and just whoever can fog up a
mirror that looks like they have a good
resume let's get it done and get them in
here no it's pretty stringent because
we've had bad experience with having the
wrong people in the building you know
people that aren't are here and unhappy
it
distracts from all the work because you
have to stop and deal with the drama
queen instead of getting your work done
you know so we don't want we try not let
drama in the building if we can help it
i mean sometimes people have bad things
happening we want to be there for them
but somebody who's in here as a taker
that's where we've had the worst
experience so yeah you go through a
whole series of interviews to weed that
out and you can't figure that out in 30
minutes
people can
they can be psychotic and
you know completely fool you for 30
minutes they can fool you anyway but
right but you know one 30-minute
interview you're not you're gonna you're
not gonna get a good team but how do you
filter that is there a question is there
a process that that breaks that down so
you're able to see
maybe what what an intention is or
whether or not there's a good fit he
just talked to him and uh you know
listen to them
if you just spend enough time and put
them in different put people in
different situations
then you'll get a feel on it um
you get a vibe on it we all i mean we
all read people pretty well if we just
would let ourselves yeah um and so just
we're sitting here going do i really
want to spend a lot of time with this
individual this is a small business even
at 1200 people it's we spend a lot of
time together we and we work hard we
work really hard um we go home at 5 30
but we work really hard while we're here
and so and i do
uh and so we just want somebody that's
aligned with that and we ask a lot of
questions and talk about who we are and
watch their reaction
to this is who we are you know and do
you want to is that who you want to be
around well no i think that's kind of
crazy okay then we kind of figured that
out you know or they give you some
indication of that that feeling or that
vibe sure now i'm really curious of your
work schedule because you have grandkids
now and how do you how has that shifted
over time with spending time with family
versus working versus helping people
how do you divvy that up do you have the
hardest times the hardest time was the
early days
because we didn't have the help and
we're trying to get the
critical mass of the business moving
trying to make payroll friday you know
that kind of stuff so i would you know i
would come in at seven and
work all day and then go to a three-hour
radio show come home from that or come
back to the office from that and then go
set up the screens in the overhead
projector across the street at the local
hotel to run financial peace university
that night those were 16 hour days and
my wife will tell you those days she was
a single mom for a while but that ran
about i guess at that schedule it was
only about two years
we were able to get critical mass and
then quickly you
quickly i wanted to delegate some of
that and so anything i could get off my
plate that would allow me to be freed up
and because i don't mind hard work but
but i do do not want to set up a
something that's not sustainable and
working like that for 20 years means you
don't have family yeah working like that
means you you lose your health or
working like that's silly but doing it
for a period of time to get something
moving well game on you know get ready
you're getting ready for the super bowl
you better get ready you know yeah and
so we did that but nowadays it's evolved
and
uh
you know the my joke with the team has
always been if i hate doing something
it's going to be real bad because i'm
just going to stop doing it
and that means that something you were
working on i might not be doing it
anymore somebody else is going to do it
or we're not doing it at all so like i
mean live events we used to do uh you
know 40 or 50 of those a year running
around with me and
then now we've got ramsey personalities
that do a lot of those and i'll go do 10
you know or 15 or something a year
which really isn't that hard to just run
into a city do an event run back home
you know it's not it's not like i'm gone
continuously right or something like
i've got friends in nashville in the
music business they live on a bus i'm
not doing that yeah at what point did
you bring on the personalities like uh
you know i've been watching george and
this is something for me where i've
noticed maybe three years ago was it
maybe two years ago you started bringing
on other people and you changed the name
of your channel from the dave ramsey
show to the ramsay show while bringing
on other people it's interesting to see
that for the most part at least from
what i saw you did everything yourself
and you were the main face and as soon
as you brought on personalities i read
all the comments and some people were
mixed about it but i think over time
people really enjoyed uh having
different perspectives how much of that
was strategic and why did you choose to
bring on other people with you
i'm 62 today
and back to my schedule when i turned 60
i quit working on fridays
so uh and and we all pretty well work
you know from
you know seven to five or whatever
around here we all the whole place you i
mean there's nobody in the parking lot
at 5 30. with the personalities when i
was 48 14 years ago
um i started getting around some
business people who
were talking you have to have a
succession plan you have to have a plan
to hand this thing off otherwise it just
dies when you die
and all the effort and everything you
put into this
dies and it seems kind of silly if
you're going to teach financial
responsibility you ought to be
responsible with your assets you know so
i uh we started going okay we need to
have some other
we need to train the next generation of
ramses to be wise owners we need to make
sure we have leadership in place that
can lead
without me in the room and without me
alive even
then how are we going to hand off the
brand and the brand those two you could
find best practices on training up the
next generation to be wise owners or
build quality leaders you can find best
practices but it's very difficult to
find someone who had handed off a brand
a singular name brand
like that to someone
and the one to one handoffs had the
worst so you had like you know the
father left it to the daughter or the
son and it just didn't work there was
too much weight on the next generation
and it was um
there was too much risk involved so
we kind of felt like god showed us to
diversify that and have a one-to-many
handoff on the brand so literally 14
years ago we started hiring and training
our first ones rachel cruz my is my
daughter and she was doing some speaking
and we had other people doing some
speaking at the time we started we first
we had horrible names for them we're
like they're message bearers they carry
the message it's like a little message
yeah
it was awful i mean
but we knew we knew where we were going
we just weren't talking about it
intelligently and uh then later they
became brand
somethings brand uh ambassadors or
something like that it was and they know
they were just called brands
we just called you bran call them brands
and they weren't a brand they're a
person yeah there's brands like uh you
know every dollar the app is a brand
financial piece is a brand a person you
know yes dave ramsey's become a brand
but that's really that
it was it was confusing everyone and so
finally someone came up with the idea of
personalities and we named them
personalities so now i have multiple
personalities
yeah so we we you know we've uh rachel
and uh you know we've got eight now or
nine
um as of today and uh you know many of
them have had uh number one best sellers
uh carrying their they're getting
tremendous speaking fees speaking all
over america
they are
high quality communicators and thought
leaders within their own right
and but the last piece of that was the
actual radio show
so we had a long before three years ago
we had a solid base of these things
happening
uh i think rachel had the first number
one bestseller uh and that was a
flight
and uh that's great land on my nose
but the uh
yeah she had the first
number one and gosh that's probably
2014 or 2012 or something like that but
yeah so we've had books going out and
other things and including them in the
smart conference and other events where
we were doing multiple people but then
the radio show we had the plan we we
didn't know what to do with it because
we weren't sure it could hand off we
thought it might die with me but then
covet
and we went okay dr john deloney talks
about mental health and loneliness and
anxiety and boy have we got some right
now and george and rachel cruz talk a
lot about hope and they're fun and funny
and god help us in the middle of
quarantine everybody needed that so i
just started i said let's just y'all get
on the air with me and let's do this and
the mistake we made at first was they
were uh
treated like a guest
yes
and that was that was more awkward
chemistry and didn't work well and we've
evolved that into a co-host and then the
more comfortable they've gotten sitting
in the co-host seat the more effective
they've been and the less hate we're
getting on it yeah but you know i told
our guys guys are coming comments people
don't like it they don't like it and i
said well were they gonna like static
that's what they're going to get when
i'm dead yeah so they might we might as
well try something you know i don't
really give a crap if they like it
because that's statics your other option
very opinionated yeah i read all the
comments so i watched lord i don't know
no comments yeah no comments comments
are
of it is that
in the beginning people aren't used to
it and they don't like what they're not
used to yeah i remember when jack first
came on the comments i don't like jax
something about all of them
would read into this be like his body
language suggests he's like you know
yeah people were like diagnosing me with
certain things they were like oh he's a
sociopath i know jack i think he's a
narcissist
that's what i said
yeah i don't know it was hilarious but
then over time now people i i don't like
graham on here i prefer jack on the
podcast and it's interesting to see how
it shifted every time it hasn't shifted
you're doing great that's not doing
what's going to do now like i prefer
george over yeah yeah you get that yeah
we get that
george is nice rachel they do like
rachel's actually very nice yeah yeah
they like rachel i've got a mean bone in
me that comes out occasionally
you have to you you're that guy i don't
yell it's a calm mean okay it's passive
snark yeah
there we go how did you guys meet we met
when i started working here as an intern
back in 2013. i kind of snuck in the
door i didn't have to go through 19
interviews because as an intern which i
don't even think we do those anymore no
we don't they're just like well he's an
issue why he's a temp he's here
you know we'll get him he'll do the work
while somebody could it be right
someone's on maternity leave this guy
knows social media we'll have him do
some things and then he'll be out of
there and uh i went hey i want to stay
here and they went well
you have it you have any skills and i
went i could do this role over here so i
jumped into email marketing
for about two and a half years went back
to social media for the personalities
that's what drew me here was our
personalities with a message to share
that was creative and gave people hope
and so i wanted to help them spread that
message through social media and
marketing and email and all those things
and over time
they had seen me on the stage at our
battle of the bands event which is one
of the ways we have a great time build
culture here internal team members form
bands a lot of failed musicians around
here in nashville i play drums by the
way yes if you need a drummer just let
me know guest appears he's not a failed
drummer though he's actually successful
you were like on tours and stuff yeah
yeah there's two dollar royalty checks i
heard about oh oh my gosh yes i haven't
gotten a royalties
the last one is probably like 60 cents i
get like 30 bucks a month from my music
career so i'm beating you in that regard
there you go so i started doing that and
they went well we should have him mc and
host because ken coleman one of our
personalities was stepping into that
role and so i started hosting events and
the video channel for the show and
curriculums you name it and last year
back in 2021 i was knighted personality
because of how much i cared about this
message and wanting to teach it and
create content around it especially for
the younger generations
it wasn't on where we knighted anyone i
don't know i mean there wasn't an
official nighting it was more of just a
meeting where they went hey you're going
to do this now and i went okay you know
which i've had about six or seven jobs
here at ramsey for george i like that
it's got a ring to it stick with that
you know actually jack and i are both
lords technically technically yeah we
did one of those uh certificates where
we own a one by one plot of land you
could be a lord for like 30 bucks online
apparently yeah
you can own a star too
i have a star
it's an nft it's yeah nft this is this
is pretty incredible
really accomplished
what was it like by the way for your
first show oh my goodness because are
they film live yeah everything's i guess
with the delay yeah with this it's like
well we can edit it out i do a big flub
and so i was live i think august 2nd of
2021
and i had just launched my very own
podcast called the fine print helping
people avoid the traps out there with
money so i was on air with dave and
there was it's a lot of pressure it's a
lot of weight to be on you know the
second largest talk radio show in
america next to dave ramsey um but at
that point i had done so many other
things in front of cameras and mics and
so i you know at first you're nervous
and you get on air and dave does the
intro and you're like holy crap i'm i'm
in it i'm inside of the matrix right now
and we just had a good time with it and
over time you get more and more
comfortable
there's not as much nerves anymore but
your body keeps the score your body
knows you are live on air in front of
millions of people don't screw up don't
say the wrong thing and by the way this
is then on youtube for the rest of time
so my kids will go back you know 20
years from now and watch old clips of me
saying stupid stuff but you know dave
led the way he's doing that so saying
stupid stuff yeah exactly what qualities
did you see in george that made you feel
comfortable putting them next to you in
all of our personalities we're looking
for uh
you know obviously a strong intellect
because a lot of the stuff we do is
quick react
and you do not have time to think about
the next day what you wish you had said
it's over you're doing an interview on
fox or you're on the air live or we're
doing a q a in front of a live audience
or whatever it is and you've got to be
able to just draw and fire
so we're looking for that
but we're also looking for that
it factor on the stage or in front of a
microphone in front of a camera and
different people have different places
that are a strength i've already said my
strength is not on camera
i enjoy the stage and i enjoy the
the uh intimacy that talk radio has
because you're dealing with just one
uh sense just just hearing and so you're
not getting the benefit of body language
or and you're listening for that pause
that means they lied or you're listening
for uh you know the the nuance of it and
30 years of doing it you begin to get it
dialed in but that the it factor in one
of those places can they lift people so
in our situation we have to be able to
put out high quality information
but doing it doing it in a way with
story and with humor that is
aspirational that's lifting you know
there has to be a motivational piece to
it if you just lift with no information
that's just fluff
but if you send out information with no
lift that's called a boring 401k meeting
and nobody wants to go to those and so
we're not doing either one of those and
so
you know we sit and talk to you know dr
john dolone we're interviewing him uh
about coming on and doing this and he
was the dean of students at a local
university but you're just sitting in a
room with him you get real quick you go
how quick he is how smart he is
and how funny he is self-deprecating and
and uh i mean this guy can do
he can handle that and what george did
was uh
george has always had that i mean he
loves to perform he's a musician he
already you know already had that uh and
we had had him in front of the camera
with the video channel as the host so we
got to see
you know could the audience love george
as a host
and you know could they could he could
he connect
and you gotta be able to do that through
these things or from the stage or
whatever it is and he obviously did that
and he's got an incredible work ethic
he's one of them of all the
personalities he's probably the one that
does the most work to prepare
before he comes on the air to do
something so he'll come in with like
three articles when we're going on the
air and go hey we could talk about this
stuff i've been looking at this this
morning and
my level of preparation is i walked in
there and hit on you know i mean it was
like because i've been doing it a long
time but i don't i don't track
that stuff but he's bringing good fresh
new ideas in chemistry from his work
ethic and so that's the type stuff we
were looking for and that he definitely
personifies it yeah i have to say the
level of preparation even when we walked
in here i looked at the desk and i'm
like wow this is similar to our desk and
i looked over i looked at the lights i'm
like wow
very similar to our lights and you said
that you've created this to somewhat
replicate the iced coffee hour and just
the level the attention to detail
i've never seen like this before our
team has very high standards and it
stems from this guy right here his uh we
call the suck bar around here and suck
bars down here for most of america most
companies and everything we do is to the
highest standard you know when we say we
do our work as unto the lord that means
we are putting our 110 percent effort in
we have a core value of excellence in
the ordinary which means the smallest
things before we went live we are
de-linting a shirt i know because we
don't want anything to distract from him
but our team i did none of this by the
way it's our amazing video crew over
here and their level of i mean
excellence and over time you know 10
years ago we weren't at the level we
were now and so we we grew over time we
got better cameras we got better at
lighting we hired even more talented
people and so over time now the bar is
just way up here and this is where we
start and if you've been to our live
event yes and so you know our production
values the things that we put out there
we want to be the best out there and
especially in the faith space there's a
lot of just like bad you know snl skit
level stuff out there and we wanted to
stand out from that crowd and do our
work as unto the lord and so that's what
we've been doing now for over many many
years well i'm curious about this
because your faith plays an important
part in the business in your life
where did that start because
you mentioned uh in one of the
interviews that you've done that it
wasn't on the way down it was on the way
up that you began to to practice and
was there a catalyst or where did that
start or what prompted that and how were
you before that point
um
well yeah the phrase was used as i met
god on the way up i got to know on the
way down meaning that first rise
in wealth um
and so i do everything backwards a lot
of people want their faith journey
begins at a point of crisis mine was at
a point in prosperity
but it deepened
with the going through that bankruptcy
walk over two and a half years and so
yeah i met god as an adult and uh but i
didn't have a a framework for
really
anything i you know how do i be a good
husband okay i'm gonna learn that from
biblical teaching i'm going to how do
you raise good kids i'm going to learn
that from a source of truth biblical
teaching i'm going to learn how to
handle money i'm going to learn
leadership i'm going to
because there you know the principles
are there
within biblical wisdom and it just gave
me a framework to form my uh
character
and uh so then you know that's why i
don't read comments
because i'm not really taking a poll
we're gonna do we're gonna do and if you
don't like it it's okay i understand you
get there's a lot of stuff you can watch
and a lot of stuff you can buy and other
places and it's okay but this is who we
are
and um we're not trying to rub it in
someone's face in terms of the our faith
but it is who we are we're not going to
be apologetic about it and then of
course you get a lot of we get a lot of
hate and a lot of stuff from that
um but you know people generally respect
someone that's very authentic you know
um
you know i i've got friends that are uh
deeply involved in a different faith
uh you know muslim or jewish or whatever
uh and
uh i tremendously respect them for being
who they are and uh it's people that
change and
blow with the wind and virtue signal
just to be try to try to let everybody
know that they're
you know i'm into this thing or i'm into
that thing so that you like them and i'm
like
that's not we're not taking a poll yeah
was there a moment for you though where
you feel like your your faith had you
know increased or was was there a
pivotal point
i guess in your 20s yeah you know it did
increase it deepened in the pain yeah
the stress level of walking through
losing everything and the strain it put
on our marriage and deepened you know
that that pain point
deepened the quality of our faith and
then you know i mean stuff around here
we go through we all go through crap you
know um
whether it's just drama or whatever it
is or a you know stress point and you go
okay
i gotta decide really what my center is
on this where am i drawing my you know
what's my source really where am i going
with this and so you know it's it's a
it's a walk it's not a singular decision
it's not a singular inflection point got
it yeah you've been married for how many
years 40 40. 40 years congratulations
thank you that's incredible
what have you noticed that's led to such
a long-standing relationship and a happy
relationship i presume yeah sharon says
we've had um 33 good years of marriage
so
exactly there we go all right
it's a good ratio
but yeah i mean thank god she's not
married to the guy she married
originally he's gotten better over time
i've grown i've learned learned how to
be a better man learn how to be a better
husband learned how to be a better
dad and uh now i have the privilege of
being a granddad and
if i'd known how great grandkids were
going to be i'd have been nicer to their
parents but yeah
but yeah uh yeah that's uh you know it's
um it is a little bit like leading a
team
or raising kids or uh just dealing with
the audience um
are you are you there to add
value and help
or are you there to take
and takers just don't
you know the parasites of this life they
don't do as well and they don't have as
high quality
experience um and the odd thing is if
you choose to serve you end up um
you know in a position of uh
of prosperity in every part of your life
and so you know sometimes when i serve a
team member
i'm asking them to work somewhere else
because they suck at their job
and so they really need to go do
something they're good at you know
and
you know we serve them by not letting
them work here um we serve the rest of
the team if someone's misbehaving
by not letting them stay in the building
and
so that people here are safe
and emotionally safe with you know that
situation so it's an act of service
sometimes to be strong and to take
action but that and that's true in
marriage it's true in leadership and
it's true certainly with kids how do you
feel that you've improved and evolved as
both a husband and a father um well i
i'm not arrived but i am better um and i
think
i'm a better leader i used to be more of
a boss
i'm a better um
but it is it's a character issue and it
really does come down to
you know deciding that you're going to
get the most joy out of adding value to
other people you're going to get the
most uh reward
out of helping someone else do their
thing
without just saying okay what can i get
out of this what can i get out of this
what can i get out of this one thing i
kind of wanted to harp back on is the
amazing culture that you guys have
established here we were told by your
head of security that once every week
you get all 1200 employees in one room
and talk to them all about the different
stuff going on with the business to for
everyone to get updated on what's going
on
how effective have you found that to and
you know make the culture better here
because i know between graham and me and
our other uh i guess partner alex
we don't have meetings and it's only
three people it's through text messages
yeah and i guess we could do a lot
better of a job with that but uh i just
want to know how that contributes to the
culture here and have you found that to
be uh i don't know to contribute
you know roi we've learned so many
things the hard way by doing it wrong
and doing it stupid
um but
what we figured out is is that where
there is no communication it's very
difficult or limited communication or
poor communication it's very difficult
to build trust and when you don't trust
the people you're working with
you all you spend all your energy
looking over your shoulder for the knife
that's coming
or all your energy spent on distract
instead of doing the thing
but when you when you when everybody has
a level of trust a high level of trust
it's never perfect because we're all
humans but when you have a high level of
trust things run really fast really
efficiently productivity goes up and so
even when there was like 10 of us we
would just get around a conference table
and go okay what are we working on
what's everybody doing because if the
right hand doesn't know what the left
hand is doing they do not assume good
they assume bad they assume it's going
to be bad and there's something bad if
they think they would rather hear bad
news that's the truth then no news
because they assume bad when it's known
use
and oftentimes there was no news or no
good or no bad news
but if you just don't talk about it when
there is bad news you don't talk about
it when uh and just let people know
what's going on and so
the uh our once a week staff meeting i
mean 1200 people 50 weeks a year or
whatever it is for 48 weeks a year we
end up in that room that's a heavy
investment in payroll if you just add
the dollars up
for an hour of that every you know every
week but it the roi on it is this level
of trust goes up because you get to hear
george up there we had a panel with all
the personalities on there the other day
this week and you know they get to see
the personalities and it was a behind
the scenes kind of joking they're
cutting up and they're you know they're
telling stories on each other and what
they're working on right now what they
dream about in the future and you know
some of the stuff that led them here and
it was it was really the team gets to
love the personalities and wants to work
with them and for them and help them and
that kind of thing and then you know we
had a guy get up and
you know talk about what's happening
with the high school curriculum that
we've got so we know what's going on
with that and they you know we're able
to get that we're changing this around
and here's the thing we're offering and
here's a test we ran that bombed and
didn't work and you know people get up
and tell what's happening in the
different areas of the business cause i
mean there's a lot of different things
going on in these buildings and you know
i don't even know sometimes what's going
on over there
if i don't you know get reports in from
the leadership team on it i would have
zero clue
uh but it's really refreshing and and
you know we have to be real careful for
it to not be boring
because you can sit over there and go
there's done anything to do with me oh
my god i'm so tired i don't want to be
home anymore and listen to this crap you
don't want to do all that so it's be
quick concise
need to be
uplifting and it needs to be truthful
and we also recognize people we use it
for recognition uh
we use it to restate the core values and
say this is hey here's the core value of
this and i'll teach on it a little bit
i'll speak
and uh that kind of thing and
so it's just a real good solid uh and
once we kind of said this is a lot of
money we really need to because we kind
of just used to walk in and
just like ad hoc do it you know but now
it's very programmed and has an agenda
and how many minutes you've got is on a
clock up there in that guy it's because
it's such a heavy investment we want it
to be good and tight
you know but uh yeah it that helps a lot
because then when the right hand knows
what the left hand is doing things move
at the speed of trust and
you know
if i don't have to think about whether
you got my back or whether you know what
the flip you're doing or whatever then i
can go do my thing and
everybody everybody's that way in the
whole building
at what point did you start doing that
uh when there was about ten
because we've i you know i'm like it's
amazing with 10 people that somebody
could be pissed off about something that
doesn't exist
you know
you know it's just like
you know they just
they just made up something in their
head driving home they're like you know
i i i just think i think he looked at me
funny today and yeah holy crap how do
you do that but yeah the mind bro the
mind does that it goes to dark places if
it doesn't have information that's true
there was a study that was done i found
really interesting that a business let's
just say has 10 employees and they asked
each of the 10 employees what percentage
do you contribute to the business's
success and they added up all of the
percentages of the 10 2000 and it was
like yeah it was like 180 200 yeah so
it's like clearly the math doesn't work
out but they over assume what they're
doing and they under assume what their
you know partners are doing yeah and you
know well he didn't like me yeah
because he walked by you and he maybe
his wife yelled at him before he walked
out this morning he's still trying to
get to a cup of coffee and leave him
alone you know how do the meetings help
with that do they flush out some of
these uh
issues well when you hear what's really
going on you go oh well that team over
there is going through crap right now
they're stressed that whole product line
they launched failed
and you know they're dealing with all
that and so maybe
you know maybe i can cut them a little
slack
i roll or something you know and uh so
you know just being in the same room
you pick up on
and dr doloney talks about this from a
psychological standpoint you regulate
off of other people that you're in the
room with you know and you you
over time you're gonna get a vibe and
you get stable and that's what's
happened actually on the air with the
personalities it took a little time for
that chemistry to lock in
and stabilize
and where we can just sit there and have
a conversation cut up and we can you
know be messed with each other mess with
the guys in the booth we can be talking
to somebody on the air kind of know
where the other one's going a little bit
and you know you know george knows where
i'm going to go and i'm hearing
he's going to take that i'm going to sit
back and let him run that one you know
and you get that but that comes from
just time spent together yeah
is there anything else that you've
learned along the way in terms of
managing a business and and being able
to scale it efficiently it seems like
you've done an incredible job of doing
that and my fear is always over scaling
taking on too much responsibility
getting ahead of ourselves
uh whereas i think you know jack is is
prominent that you know we should be
expanding more we should be taking on
more
how do you find a balance for that you
know it's just it's uh it's worth it but
it's hard
uh it's not easy because you're dealing
with people and um
we teach when we're teaching entree
leadership teaching small business
people about the same types of questions
that you know people are going to be
your greatest blessing
they're going to be the biggest line
item payroll on your p l
your largest investment in other words
and they're also going to be the
greatest source of pain
if you love people and you care about
people and you say okay i'm going to
take care of that person we're gonna do
this and then you turn around six months
later and they quit for a nickel an hour
or more or something i'm like damn you
forgot about that time i gave you a car
you know it's like wow that hurt you
know it leaves a mark and but you know
that doesn't mean you can't still turn
around and do something good for
somebody and so
um we continue to pour into continue to
love people well continue to treat them
like we'd want to be treated
and continue to fire them if they don't
fit in and if they're not gonna
you know align with who we are
and so and the team you know it's like
when we're bringing on new team members
i i make them a promise i promise you're
not gonna have to work with people a bad
character and people who will not play
to win you're not going to play you
don't have to run with you're a
thoroughbred you don't have to be you
don't have to work with donkeys we're
going to regularly do donkey ectomies
that's funny so we got about 20 minutes
left i think it would be interesting if
we shift and talk a little bit about the
economy the stock market real estate
um where do you see the economy heading
over the next let's say one to two years
because i think we have a lot of
interesting catalysts going on with
inflation that may have peaked um
student loan forgiveness that just came
up which might have some implications
down the line where is your stance about
where we are
today it's obviously uh
today we're in a bad place
but we're not in a devastating place
but if you want to call where we are
today prosperity you would be ignorant
um and you would have to have some kind
of a political agenda
because any person that can look at
life and look at numbers and look at the
indicators in the economy the
the metrics can tell we're not this is
not a time of prosperity
now the good news is there's always
opportunities
in up times and there's opportunity and
down times and so that you know it may
be a time that you take more space that
you expand your uh your footprint that
you expand your market share
downtime is a really good time to do
that because a lot of people are sitting
on the sidelines whining sucking your
thumb when things are slow and so it's a
good time to be a hard charger
in the middle of that in terms of your
personal reaction to it but no there's
no question that we're
you know running a the gdp is running
flat to down just a little to up just a
little bit which is basically hovering
around recession
we
did have officially a recession two
consecutive quarters of a downturn i
don't care how you want to define it
that's what they teach an econ class so
but it wasn't much of one it's like
quarter of a percent it was a joke
as recessions go it's a pitiful one you
know but it but it's also not booming
it's not a time of great prosperity and
the fields aren't full you know or that
kind of thing so we definitely have that
the inflation thing was aggravated by
washington but certainly was caused by
the
economic suppression
around covid i mean we shut down the
economy
when you shut down an economy the size
of the united states of america the size
of the world and you want to restart it
you're gonna have shortages
uh that's called supply chain maybe you
can call it whatever you wanna call it
but you're gonna have shortages and when
you have shortages you're always going
to price increases thus you're gonna
have inflation
and so
uh you know
it makes a real case for
we destroy we economically destroyed
some people's lives
with the covid policies sure
was it worth it well we can argue about
that it's kind of late but we could
argue about it in the name of flattening
the curve if you remember that that's
what we were all doing everybody sits at
home so the factories all shut down so
they're not making cars so there's a car
shortage so cars go up i mean for the
first time and
since they've been made used cars went
up in value never in the history of the
car has that occurred and never again
will it unless you do something stupid
of the economy like shut the whole
freaking thing down
um
in the name of flattening the curve but
the ripple effect is that of that that
you get inflation
uh and then you get people think you
know the buying administration is
tinkering with the energy policies in
the name of green and so they're
shutting down you know domestic oil
production are greatly curtailing and
making an unfriendly environment for
them for sure intentionally in the name
of a green policy and you can argue
about whether that's the right thing to
do or not but you can't argue about the
fact that that caused gas prices to be
five dollars i mean
uh that's where it comes from it's a
shortage
shortage scarcity always it's a simple
supply demand curve uh and shortage
always creates that so we've got
inflation as a result of those things
uh i kind of think that's going to level
on out i don't think it's going to
continue if the fed will quit screwing
around with it but they're they can't
they're like a mad scientist
so um
but
the uh the real estate market you know
was crazy it was quite hot
but a lot of that was scarcity people
sitting around looking at their house
going this this house sucks i don't
spend enough time here to realize how
bad it sucks and that you know but i'm
quarantined i'm stuck here so now when i
as soon as this is over i'm going to go
change houses and boy by god they did or
i'm getting out of this state we had a
migration that occurred you know so
there's all kinds of
weird stuff that's um
probably a once-in-a-lifetime events in
the real estate world so uh my you know
my guess is and really if you look back
for the last 30 years i've been doing
this it pretty well plays out that
this too shall pass and
you know regardless of
how smart or how dumb the people in
washington are
eventually these the
wrinkles will be smoothed out of this
and 36 months from now we should see a
completely different economy than we do
today yeah i don't think inflate these
this is not long-term inflationary cycle
this is caused by shortages yeah where
do you see the opportunities today for
most people i know you're talking about
expanding but i would say for the
average person who's maybe concerned
that
home prices are going to go down maybe
they believe that or they believe that
you know stock prices are still high
things are going to crash
you know my job is going well but
where's the next opportunity i know
short term where the next opportunity is
but i do know long term
i i'm buying mutual funds in real estate
that's what i do
and that's my personal
wealth building plan it's not really
complicated um why because i'm pretty
dead i'm sure
that an 80-year history in the stock
market of you know of the economy
getting stronger and stronger those
companies continue to make profit and
that profit results in value of those
stocks going up and over time
you know we're as a grouping the stock
market the the what you're saying is is
the american economy going to
permanently go down and stay down if you
say the stock market's going to go down
and stay down that's what you're saying
and
that i just don't believe that and it's
not it's not weird it's just there's a
80-year track record you can look at and
go uh didn't happen
went down here came back up went down
here came back up went down
uh you know with quarantine dropped you
know yeah through the floor and then was
back 18 months later six months later
whatever it was back up to where it was
so um you know
i'm just going to continue to invest
this long-term long-term long time i i
just you know i
got in the real estate business as we
said in 1978 i mean come on and so and
those houses that i was selling then
yeah don't you wish you owned all of
them yeah oh my gosh for what they're
worth today oh of course now when you
invest in real estate do you prefer
residential or commercial uh these days
it's commercial just because of skate
the number of dollars
involved and um real residential is a
great place to get started i've still
got i don't know 10 15 houses or
something in our portfolio but just
because i hardly ever sell anything sure
just buy and keep it forever buy quality
properties add a deal keep them forever
but um
commercials give me better roi
right now then uh of course our stuff's
100 paid for we don't borrow money but
um it's giving me the best internal
rates of return and cash on cash roi
uh overall i've got one piece of
commercials just sucks i can't get it
rented but um but the rest of them are
doing really really well and of course
the residential is all jamming and the
rents are down the rents have gone up uh
this year
last two years pretty dramatically but
um still not making
cash on cash or cash on value sure what
the value if i took that million dollar
house or that 700 000 house and i you
know what's my return on it cash on cash
isn't that great it's okay
but uh even with high rents you know
what do you think about the movement
right now it seems that landlords are
evil they're taking advantage of their
tenants
it seems like there's been a shift over
the last two years with rents and house
prices going up that buying a house
right now is is is immoral
what are your thoughts on that because
that's a movement that i've seen it's
been
taking a stronger hold than i would have
expected yeah that comes and goes too um
i mean when people are hurting and
they're scared socialism is it gets in
vogue
and being angry
australians call it tall poppy syndrome
uh or which is an aristotle
thing actually isn't you know the poppy
that gets higher has to be cut down and
so anybody that makes money must be
destroyed anybody that's successful must
be destroyed so that we're all equal and
uh which you know as we have figured out
we are not all equal it doesn't work out
that way
i mean it turns out that brad paisley is
better at playing a guitar than i am
and uh we're not all equal and it turns
out that other people you know my friend
brad thor sells he does a fiction book
on spies and sells 15 million per copy
which pisses me off
but you know we're not all equal but i
don't think brad should be destroyed
because he sold more books than i did
yeah i'm happy for him
and it didn't cost me anything except
when i bought a copy but i mean it was
not you know so it's uh
that kind of stuff but i it's um
at the core of that is the kind of the
wealth inequality concepts the movement
or the
uh
the socialism idea that you know if
you're somehow
a capitalist that you are evil
um and really the core of all of that is
uh two of the deadly sins envy and
jealousy
jealousy is i want what you have envious
i don't think you should have it
and this is envy you should be you know
you should be it should be taken away
from you
because you bought a house and charged
rent
um
i mean one of the one of the things got
really excited about something i said on
the air and trashed me i can't remember
who it was and
one of the youtubers or somebody and uh
because i said yeah i'm going to raise
my rents i'm like well you're not a
christian i'm like what's goddess
christians don't raise rents
what kind of dumb butt statement is that
of course we raise rents you know we
charge market rent it's not evil you're
not evil you're providing a house and
you don't have to live there well where
are your people going to live they can't
afford it somewhere else you know i grew
up in a neighborhood that was over the
tracks from this neighborhood and when
we were growing up we went hey rich
people live over there i can't afford to
live over there
that's what we said
you know and i can't afford to live
there anymore the rents went up and you
know if you make forty five thousand
dollars a year you cannot live in
manhattan hello you can't pay the rent
welcome to life uh you're going to make
more if you're going to live in
manhattan uh that's how it works well
it's evil no it's not evil it's just
math
math is not evil it's not nobody's doing
anything wrong nobody's out to hurt you
it's just you you know you don't get a
pass on math because you got your little
butt hurt feelings yeah i will say i did
make a mistake uh two years ago i made a
comment to kevin o'leary who reviewed my
portfolio and we got to a property and
we explained the cash we looked at one
property says well the rents on this is
lower than every other place that you
have and i said well i've never raised
the rent on that tenant and it was 10
years i had not raised the rent she was
a great tenant never a single issue
always paid on time treated the place
like her own
and i figured you know what i wouldn't
raise the rent makes my life easy don't
have to think about it she's there
she was a tenant ten years later had
some issues and i i don't want to go
into detail but i wish i i should have
raised the run that was a huge mistake
that i made looking back
that i should have done that as as part
of a smart business to exactly no it's
also psychological okay because she
started to get confused at some point
who owned the house
yeah
and so with our tenants and with our
advertisers we go up every year
25
i don't know but we go up every year we
don't any want anyone to go uh well i'm
doing him a favor by being here and so
no this is a transaction i mean you
you're going to pay the rent and you get
to stay
this is a transaction and i'm going to
take care of stuff that's broken and i'm
going to be kind to you and nice to you
but you are not entitled because you
have been here a long time to
cheaper rent now i i will you know maybe
not raise it all the way to market to
not push somebody out because of the
cost of a turnover but that's an
economic decision yeah that's not a i'm
doing you a favor and you know and then
if you run your business well then you
can choose
as a one-off in a situation to be kind
to someone like we had a tenant that was
going through cancer treatments and the
family was just destroyed and so we not
only uh didn't go up on rent we just
gave them like three months with no rent
just to help them but that was an act of
kindness
and generosity
that was not a statement of previously
we've been doing something evil and now
we're going to do something good no
instead and we're having a transaction
here pay your rent you get to stay
this is the value of the property
and you can't it doesn't work anymore
um and
oh you've got a life thing and i've got
some margins so i can just be kind i can
just be generous
and give you give you a little time off
and we did do that
um we took over we bought a building one
time in a foreclosure that had a a
church operation operating a daycare and
the daycare was primarily serving uh the
underserved area a lower income
situation and they didn't have much
margin in running that thing and they
were run non-profit we sat down with the
guys and
you know we ended up giving them the
first six months after we bought the
building free
so they could get up get things running
but it wasn't it wasn't
because charging rent was evil it was
because we were able to help these
people get their business situated and
that was a nice good thing to do
generosity-wise but no it's ridiculous
so we always go up on rents every year
yeah i wanted to learn yeah there's a
certain investing philosophy i know you
feel very strongly about which is debt
and i'm assuming you probably share that
sentiment with dave
so graham and i have had very unique
experiences with that graham utilized
debt extremely well to grow his real
estate portfolio in the beginning he
took on a decent amount of debt
and was able to leverage because of that
i have had a good and a bad experience
with debt uh i bought a house i wouldn't
have been able to afford without debt
and since i bought it i've appreciated
maybe i've gained probably 90 100 000 or
so in equity on the flip side i had a
stock portfolio that's kind of my fun
portfolio and i brought it up from 20 or
so thousand to like 75 000
and right around 75 000 i went in on
margin
yeah so i know where this is going yeah
and uh unfortunately that was in
december so
yeah and the timing shot it was really
bad too i thought inverse jax trades
you'll make it you really would yeah
unfortunately yeah but uh i basically
thought i was a genius because i was
making money all last year and i'm like
you know what i got this i'm just going
to continue doing what i have been doing
but this time going to leverage now i
had the money i had the cash but i
decided leverage why not it's on
robinhood so i did that and uh currently
sitting at about 7 000
uh from 75 000 and uh you know so i've
had both good and bad experiences with
that and i wanted to know
because maybe the average person isn't
as responsible as maybe graham is with
that maybe they're like me on my robin
hood thing do you say debt is bad
because for the average person that is a
good principle to live by and with that
i kind of agree with you however if
people do utilize debt in an effective
way such as graham he's very responsible
very well researched on you know the
markets and how he can leverage his
money with debt do you think that that
is a more effective way to to grow fast
if you're calculated with it it is a
more effective way to grow fast
if that's your goal
but what people leave out of the
discussion is that you've increased your
risk
exponentially more debt equals more risk
period
and so uh
you know after i went broke i had to
analyze and go okay what went wrong here
and because was it see i had never lost
money on a flip
i was not behind on the notes
they just called them
they had the ability to do that because
it was commercial paper it wasn't
traditional mortgages it was 90 day
paper and um
so i you know
what it amounted to was and i so i had
proven track record of making money i
mean i did
i probably owned 2 000 pieces of real
estate in my life and so i was doing a
lot of flips
and some of i was doing in 24 hours
you know i just buy them and flip them
to another investor and make 10 grand
and keep walking you know that kind of
stuff so i was doing a hundred percent
financed
i didn't put any money
i didn't have any money so i talked a
guy into giving me a hundred percent
deal on this house i flipped it i made
10 grand
hey and i talked him into doing it again
then i talked him into doing it again
then i talked him into doing a million
too and uh with that one bank and yeah
so it set me up and so after i crashed i
kind of had to go through a csi you know
an autopsy and go okay why did the
patient die you know so what i you know
because everything i was taught i grew
up in the real estate business and when
you when you're in the real estate
business as a profession one of the
rules is they take your risk meter out
and they sit on the table and they break
it so you have no you have no ability to
perceive risk because everything's good
everything's going up and you know and
you know it always works and uh the the
mythology that just because something
worked once it's always going to work
every time so
uh i i had to go through kind of a
healing of my heart in that regard and
go oh i meant this is risk
uh oh wait a minute opm other people's
money yeah
it's kind of got that get-rich-quick
slimy vibe to it you know and all that
but there are people that intelligently
more intelligently than that use debt
and so there's a spectrum there but even
those are
taking on risk and so when you have
buffett says when the when the tide goes
out you can tell who's skinny dipping
so when you stress test with an economic
problem of some kind
uh outside variable or inside variable
inside your organization or your life
inside your portfolio or the economy
like a quarantine type thing comes up or
inflation or recession and you stress
test your theories
um
you know you can tell who's skinny
dipping when the tide goes out and uh
you if your theories don't last and so
the only one i've ever found
and this comes back to my faith journeys
where it started the borrowers slaves
the lender i can find nowhere in
scripture that debt was used to bless
people
and so then i got to think okay do i
believe that or do i believe my academic
training i've got a degree in finance
and i know how to run an irr you know
and i know what the irr looks like
without
with uh with debt and without debt and
it's not nearly as good
unless you're leveraged but you can run
an irr through the roof with leverage
guess what's left out of the irr
calculation there's no math inserted for
risk
the irr is agnostic to risk it doesn't
recognize it
and so while you see this great rate of
return there's zero risk showing up in
there the chance that you lose the thing
or the chance that the stress brings on
your life or what it does to your
marriage or what it does to your body to
carry around the weight of that
none of that is parlayed into there and
real estate is unique in that way
because other investment vehicles teach
us to mathematically insert risk for
instance two mutual funds you would
never compare
an aggressive growth stock mutual fund
with a with a growth in income
okay and if you look at the chart you
know the growth in income is kind of
like this and the aggressive growth like
this right and that's the risk factor
and the highs and lows on that y'all
probably know this is called for our but
for our audience at home the the change
the rapid change is measured by a thing
called a beta
and a beta is a statistical measure of
risk it's a math number and so a beta of
1.0 for those at home means that that
particular mutual fund is exactly what
the stock market is it's s p 500 it's
doing what the stock market's doing a
beta of 2.0 it means it's twice as risky
so this is an aggressive growth emerging
market type stock fund portfolio and so
it's twice as risky as the market so you
would the way you would adjust for risk
between
a beta of a 0.8 which might be like a
growth in income versus a beta of 2.0 is
you insert the beta in an inverse in the
math formula and you adjust for risk so
you can compare these two apples to
apples even though after risk a
post-risk analysis we don't do that in
real estate no one ever talks about that
in real estate it doesn't even come up
and so if but we have kind of a brain
and our brain says oh wait a minute if
i'm a 110 leveraged in real estate
that's probably not good
you know
where would you say the risk is though
let's say on a three percent mortgage or
an interest rate that's below inflation
because from my perspective it seems
like there's less risk it is and having
cash in the bank then tied up in a
property that might not be as easily
accessible that in the event of a job
loss or something happens you'll have
cash that you could easily access versus
in a property where it might be
difficult to take out like if you need
the money like something comes up um and
it exceeds your emergency fund that
maybe it's harder to tap into if that's
your last case result well the the
difference is are we talking about the
shortest path to bankruptcy or the
shortest path to wealth
this what you're describing is not going
to lead you to bankruptcy
and so it's a nuanced argument at that
point okay and so like you know uh
because we're not talking about a
get-rich-quick hundred percent
you know portfolio and you're just
trying to use an inflationary number to
offset your interest rates and that that
that doesn't play long term but you know
where you've got a high cash position a
high equity position
lower debt well guess what your risk is
so low
that it's
that the debt represents that your beta
would not be a 2.0 it would be a 0.25
you know but there is still a risk
that is there that is not there if the
house is 100 paid for the property's 100
paid for because then if your tenant
doesn't pay because of pandemic oh and
by the way you can't evict them
because of a moratorium on evictions uh
and so you got zero cash coming in and
nothing you can do about it or are they
going to chapter 13 take six months to
get them out
um yeah you got zero cash coming in and
not squat you can do about it uh and
legally you're gonna you're gonna get
real criminal crap if you start messing
with those things right so you cannot
and so you're writing jacks
i'm not
and i'm sitting here smiling and going
okay we got a big pile of cash and we
got all these buildings paid for and we
had entire segments of our revenue just
evaporate with the quarantine like live
events didn't exist obviously right that
kind of stuff and we're going this ain't
good because we're gonna if this thing
goes down into the red and we start
burning that cash what's our burn rate
and how long before we start leadership
doesn't take pay and how long after that
before
we start having to furlough people or
lay people off and we're running those
calculations during that short period of
time that we were off and uh but we did
not have added to that
the burn rate of the rent burning
through the cash yeah uh or the how are
the payment on the buildings i mean can
you imagine the payment on these
buildings if i had been burning that
cash during that holy crud yeah but you
know so one less thing to worry about
right but it's a risk analysis is what
it is
and if you
100 i run 100 debt-free portfolio and so
i have zero pressure to
our virtually zero pressure to
make that property inordinately perform
in a stressful situation so i make
different decisions about tenants i
don't need a tenant
and so i don't get as many bad ones
because i'm willing to go yeah
we'll sit here another month
if it takes another month to fill it
that's better than putting that bozo in
there he's going to change his harley
oil in the living room i can feel it you
know you know what i'm talking about and
so but but i remember when i had
payments on properties in my other life
and i'd be going honey i got to make
this dead gum payment i need to get a
tenant in here and you know all sudden
your little irr thing you did when you
bought the property and you ran your pro
forma out on a you know you ran out the
noi and you run the whole thing out
through there all of a sudden you go oh
that's out the window you're just like
crap i gotta make the payment and you
forget thinking about that and so you
kind of have that same look here and
he's talking about seven thousand
dollars a minute ago you know and it's
um but
hey dude i did it i did it with millions
so you're not you're not nearly as dumb
as i am but uh yeah that's where it
comes from so i you know
the uh uh
100 debt-free works in prosperity
uh and it works in down times the more
debt you use the more prosperity is
required in the marketplace for you to
succeed
because to overcome the risk that's all
it is and so i just decided i'm wounded
i'm not borrowing money period and joe
and susie consumer
you know when i can get them 100 out of
debt their probability of walking into a
million million dollar net worth
increases dramatically
dramatically because they're not trying
you know of all the 10 000 millionaires
we interviewed 10 167 millionaires in
our largest study of millionaires ever
done
uh
precisely zero said
i became a millionaire because i
borrowed all i could on my personal
residence at three percent and i
parlayed that in the stock market and it
made me a millionaire
none of them said that
zero
z that's bizarre
i mean zero
said that zero also said you know my
airline miles that i got on my credit
card you know
that's him
yeah
so i'm the opposite i'm like yeah
because i borrowed how many credit cards
do you have probably 10 10.
they're all paid off they're all paid
off there's zero balance i couldn't
remember which messing with him does
that mean no i love it
no that was that was you're going easier
i look at the flights today just because
i love your grounds
because i love you man hotels we booked
a whole trip to hawaii uh last year all
paid for yeah because you couldn't
afford it otherwise yeah but it was free
it was a free trip yeah that's the way
you spend 12 to 18 more when you use
plastic on average and i don't think so
i am so i don't know the behaviors
i'm sure they do i had to buy him his
iced coffee this morning dave
you know i brought a coffee from the
airbnb that i made there and i still
have it in a plastic cup because i knew
that i just habitually make my own
coffee my default is to spend money you
are frugal yeah the default is always
i'm not going to spend i'm known for
being happy
that's illegal is it cheaper
i'm getting better you are getting
better i'm very proud of you well thank
you guys so much i see we're running
over a little bit on time but i don't
want to hold this up thank you guys so
much i'm so honored to be with you guys
love what you do love the podcast you
guys are amazing thank you so much part
of it thank you yeah thank you for for
agreeing to do this thank you george for
setting us up absolutely and we got
another really exciting video planned
right after this so make sure to check
out the main channel right now it's
worth it and uh i'll see you very
shortly appreciate you guys thank you
thank you
see i could have done this for another
few hours
you